Not only is Jupiter
the largest planet in our solar system,
it's now also the planet
with the most moons.
Astronomers discover 12 more moons
orbiting the gas giant
using a high powered
telescope in Hawaii about 20 months ago.
And that brings the total number of moons
orbiting Jupiter to 92.
Saturn has the second most moons with 83,
followed by Uranus and Neptune.
And in comparison, Mercury and Venus
both have zero.
Joining us right now is Adam Frank.
He's a professor
of astrophysics at the University
of Rochester in New York.
He's also the author
of Light of the Stars
Alien Worlds and the Fate of Our Earth.
Professor Frank, so good to see you.
Good to see you again.
Great.
So what can we learn from these findings
Well, the main thing that you learn from
this is that Jupiter, which is,
you know, the king of the solar system,
has this enormous capacity
just to Hoover in everything. Right.
Jupiter is
a giant vacuum cleaner for space debris,
which is really important for us
because we might not be here
if it wasn't for Jupiter
acting kind of like the big brother
of the solar system
and clearing material out
that normally might have pummeled
the Earth and sterilized the big bag.
More evidence of that role
that Jupiter plays. Right.
So so NASA's now is expected
to launch a mission
next year
that will visit Jupiter
and its moon, Europa.
Tell us a little bit about Europa.
What makes this moon so important?
Yeah, Europa is insane.
I mean it into solar.
And we didn't know this like a while back
when I was a kid.
Europa has an ocean.
Europa actually has twice
the amount of water that Earth does.
So its ocean is larger.
It's 100 miles deep
and it's covered by a ten mile
thick layer of ice.
So who knows what is down there?
There could be an entire aquatic
ecosystem there.
So the
discovery that we had these ocean moons
and there's others around the large,
large planets as well,
really was groundbreaking
in terms of understanding
whether there's other places for life
in the solar system.
Forget the universe, just in the solar.
So with that much water frozen
or otherwise,
it's it's
almost certain in your view
that there would be some forms of life.
Well, I wouldn't go that far.
And scientists
have to be very conservative sorry.
But it's the thing that's really cool is
the Jupiter is so big,
its gravity is constantly twisting
the insides of Europa,
turning it into kind of warm taffy.
And so then at the bottom of that
100 mile deep ocean,
you could have thermal vents
where there's all kinds
of chemical shenanigans going on.
And that's the kind of place
where you might expect life to start.
We think life started that way on Earth.
So but the problem for us
is how do you get through
six miles of ice? Right.
I mean, that's a that's a pretty.
Even the guys in Minnesota
would have a hard time getting through.
How about that?
So we probably would know
how to probe down there.
But it certainly is
it is one of the most profound mysteries
in the solar system.
So pretty cool.
Yeah, it is.
I like shenanigans.
I like the way you put it.
So elsewhere
in outer space of NASA's curiosity rover
found some of the clearest evidence
yet of an ancient lake on Mars.
And scientists
say it's the best evidence
of water and waves
they've seen this entire mission.
So why is this significant?
And is how promising might it be?
Can we just have
a moment
before we do anything else
to freak out about that picture?
Those are like 4 billion year old waves.
Those are like when you walk,
it is amazing.
And you see the ripple right
and this is another planet.
And these are
those are 4 billion years old.
I mean, there weren't even dinosaurs
here yet.
So it's okay now.
I've got to get past that.
I like this.
But these are my nightmares about this
is that it's
actually really concrete evidence.
We've been building up
evidence that Mars,
which right now is a frozen desert,
once had oceans, or at least huge
lakes with water
rippling up on the surface.
And this is the perfect place
for life to get started.
So this is really clear evidence
that Mars,
first of all, underwent
some pretty dramatic climate change.
You want to talk about climate change,
but that also more
is still under the ground in Mars,
that life has managed to hold on.
Maybe there are microbes just, you know,
a couple of meters below that surface
which are still kind of,
you know, hanging on
and doing their thing. They're still.